this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell joined today by ramsay
personality best-selling author ken
coleman we are taking your calls so
let's talk about your life your work
your money what's stressing you out
what's keeping you up at night we're
here to give you the right next step and
help you on the journey the phone number
to call triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five eric is
kicking us off he's in san antonio texas
eric welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
my wife and i uh we we recently turned
our side hustle
into a full-time business we own a dog
concierge business i started thank you
we started it in order to pay off our
debt
um and which we successfully did and
then
we did that over the course of one year
and then we turned our side hustle into
our full-time business and so my
question
is really regarding our next step we
want to keep doing this we want to keep
expanding and
so the money that we have in the bank we
have
about thirty thousand dollars in our
personal savings we have about five to
ten thousand dollars in our business
savings account
zero debt and
we are trying to figure out if we should
move our business to a country estate
facility
to run our business there or if we
should get an in-town commercial
location
the issue being that if we do the
commercial location it's got a much
higher risk because of the much higher
overhead
yeah
let me ask you this you clearly have
these two options the country estate and
then the in-town facility
based on the market meaning your
particular area where you see your
business coming from is it clear that
one of these is better than the other as
it relates to
accessibility flexibility for your
customer
not necessarily so the issue with going
with the country route is that we would
lose about half of our business but the
actual demand because we don't have a
website yet we've built our business 100
off of referrals wow and so what we
would have a website build we basically
have that up ready to go
so we would launch our website etc you
know start some advertising and so with
the demand that we've analyzed
we could do either route and we think
we'd be profitable profitable it's just
the commercial route seems like it would
have a much higher rate of return but
we would also get to
you know service our current clientele
100 and not lose anybody but it does
come with that risk of having a
eight to ten to twelve thousand dollar
lease potentially having to hire some
employees right away rather than going a
more conservative route but at the same
time having to lose about half of our
clientele
yeah well okay so
i could tell by your voice in the tone
that you're leaning towards one
direction and uh but i want to know if
that's true which direction before you
got on the phone to talk to us which
direction were you leaning
i'm leaning towards the country route my
wife is leaning towards the uh
commercial in town place okay and so
we're talking about uh and what would
you be your expense to the business for
the country estate
the country estate would raise our
expenses by about
three thousand to four thousand dollars
a month um our quarter one we profited
forty four 000 and we turned away about
15 000 a business because we run our
business out of our house right okay so
with and then the uh corporate i mean
the downtown place is going to cost you
about another 8 to 10 an increase
yes well that um plus we would have to
get a you know pos system for you know
processing how much is that going to be
handling
um i haven't gotten that one it my guess
is you know 500 bucks a month yeah okay
so here's the simple answer george you
weigh in on this but the simple answer
here eric is
uh number one you don't have to move now
you know it's it's one of those things
where you're feeling this well we're
going country estate or we're gonna go
downtown and the reality is is that you
could stay where you are and just keep
doing what you're doing growing slow
growing smart and keep stacking money up
i'd like to see that account have a lot
more money so that's a viable option
let's call that option one option two
for sake of discussion we'll call the
country estate option three in town so
here's what you have to do
you have to decide do you really have to
move now and is now the best time to
move i think that's the question i want
you to answer first
right absolutely and so maybe i should
have preferenced that um but
so with with where we're at we're in a
rental house
um and
so we are we're essentially in the city
and so we have the risk of for example
if if somebody found out um you know
that we were running our business from
here we could potentially get put out of
business tomorrow okay all right well
that is good information that's
emergency that's my wife and i yeah plus
my wife and i circumstances are not
ideal with us being in our house as well
100 okay so we solved that you got to
move all right yeah so what the homework
is is the math is i've got to figure out
what's that point of service sale all
that system going to cost for real and i
got to look at how much more would we
increase our clientele by moving into
the city or moving into this facility in
the city and then you start to weigh
that out what's increased revenue going
to look like
and then i i stack that increase revenue
on one side of the paper and on the
other side i'm going okay my increased
cost and so this is just a numbers game
it's a math game it feels really scary
but when you put the number side by side
you get everything out on paper and we
look at it george now it's just a math
equation yeah and eric i want you here's
what i found in business and in life he
with the most patience the most
information and the most options is
always going to win and so i think you
need more options i don't like you're
back against the wall was just saying
this is it or this is it so i'm going to
keep doing my research find out what the
other options are whether it's in town
or country estate how can we get this
lease down and how can we build up that
client base really fast i'd go on
squarespace today or whatever website
program you want to use get that website
up it'll take an hour to use a template
and get your name out there and then
start a referral program with your
clients so start to get creative with
marketing to get those clients up and
move slow always move at the speed of
cash which it sounds like you guys have
done a great job of doing so far
and on top of that plug into all the
resources we have with entree leadership
that's going to be immensely helpful to
get plugged in with other business
owners who are on the same journey
probably a lot of folks in the in the
animal world i know at our events can we
have a lot of people who do dog training
dog concierge it's a booming business
yeah what is that what is the what do
you make most of your money on in the
concierge
space what are you doing so with with
ours we make about 60 with daycare we
make um about 30 with boarding and then
10 percent with drop-ins training etc
okay yeah cool i think george is right
that's a really great challenge is to
find another facility and another
facility and another facility now you
got to do this quickly
um but absolutely
both of yeah both of them are great
options we're just in my personal mind
the in town one has more risk because
what if something goes wrong with and so
that's where my thought is but we'll
play with that after a bit
yeah so you need to you don't have to do
on this call but you need to also say
what could go wrong
what are the chances or what would have
to be true for these things to go wrong
and then how could we mitigate that risk
meaning it is a risk but if we do this
this and this it's not going to break us
this is just digging a little bit more
and playing this whole thing out and
then again the safe route is never bad
we could do the country estate for a
while george and then we can move
with the
puppies yeah but i like this plan uh
being an entrepreneur equals risk so how
do we mitigate that risk and make sure
we make wise decisions that are going to
help our future and get on the same page
with your wife hey this is a great
question they turned a side hustle into
their full-time dream job coming up next
we're going to talk about side hustles
some of you just need a great side
hustle idea to get out of debt some of
you want to turn that side hustle into a
full-time gig don't miss that we'll get
there more of that on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and we are taking your calls the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we are here to talk about your life your
money your work your relationships it's
all about you and we do it right here in
front of you on the ramsay show
dan joins us up next he is in hartford
connecticut dan welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing thank you for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help
um so i um i have a good question for
you guys i'm self-employed
i'm a marriage and family therapist
um in connecticut
and
i was an independent contractor years
ago
um for i'm a woman and then i became an
employee and then i went out my own
starting this year
um this past january so
um i'm making
monthly contributions to my roth
and then monthly contributions to my sep
i have a goal of what i want to achieve
this year gross wise
um but with the way the market is and
my wife and i have a a one-year-old i
was wondering you know i read dave's
books i wanted to kind of get your
insights on should i stick with maybe
year one investing
fifteen percent of my growth
um
and or should i wait until the end of
the year still contribute to my sep each
month and then my roth each month
and then at the end of the year if i can
fully max out my step
um is that something you guys recommend
or taking year one sticking with
uh the fifteen percent
that's awesome daniel i'm glad you're
doing this a lot of folks that are
self-employed don't even realize they
have investing options and uh they
retire broke so i don't know what you're
thinking about i really was i was a i
was completely blind no idea what i was
doing when i was 25. i don't even know
what i was doing but how old do you know
i do i think of a little bit
was that how old are you now
uh i'll be 39 in august fantastic well
the good news is you got lots of time
too so that's great you've been
investing so to your question we
recommend 15 of your household income in
retirement in baby step four which means
you're out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund is that you
um
great
okay and then once once you hit baby
step seven which means you have a paid
for house then i'm okay with you
increasing that number so do you have a
paid for house
uh currently no i don't no that's the
only that i have in my home okay cool
well anything on top of that fifteen
percent i'm going to throw at the
mortgage
okay how quickly can you pay off that
mortgage
um
i have to i have to i haven't thought
about that yet i'll often kind of give
that more thought um i can probably come
up with a plan for that yeah um
it's it's kind of everybody's like well
if you can max out you know hear other
people say if you can max out your chef
do it and then i'm like
okay well that sounds great and i'm
reading you know all of these books i'm
going all right 15 but i can also you
know
you know um
i have my emergency fund my wife and i
and we have no other debts so it's you
know and then i get nervous because then
i see the market so it's kind of like
um i'm looking at all the different you
know all the different avenues so
um i kind of want to kind of get your
thoughts on sorry to stick with the 15
and try to tackle more the mortgage or
should i just max out this app and keep
going the way i'm going yeah it's a
great question and our plan is is all
about financial peace it's all about
mitigating that risk and when you have a
paid for house you just removed your
biggest expense
and when you do that you're going to
have so much more money to invest for
the rest of your working career and so
this is kind of a tortoise in the hair
mentality
and so i love the idea that you want to
max out that set but there's a time and
place for that within the ramsey plan
and that's once you have that house paid
for what's your mortgage right now
what's the payment every month
my wife and i we pay our more mortgages
around i want to say 2600. okay so let's
do some quick uh napkin math here that's
over 31 000 a year that you will have
freed up when that mortgage is gone so
now think about that thirty one thousand
dollars a year that you can use to
invest and to build wealth and you're
gonna pay off your house within the next
ten years i imagine if you're following
our plan i
yeah i mean that's i have to get my wife
on board with the plan
and so is she not on board at all with
any of this
um
she's very i think we're both very good
with money and
um we have no debts except for our our
mortgage and
both we you know both work very hard as
well as you know millions and millions
of other americans do
and it's
you know it's it's
it's a little bit of a challenge because
um i've kind of had to scale back my
business obviously with a one-year-old
and sure um and i know i could do more
so i'm trying to i'm compromising a
little bit on that end
um but i've also been reading dave's
book i'm on i think his fourth book i
just bought his fifth book this weekend
so it's like awesome i can see it
definitely the light at the end of the
tunnel and it makes it makes sense it
you know it takes work but it definitely
makes sense
well here's what i'm going to do for you
i'm going to gift you ramsay plus and
it's a one-year membership that includes
all the videos in financial peace
university every dollar plus or premium
budgeting tool what i want you to do dan
is go through the financial peace
university videos with her because i
think it'll get her excited about the
shared common goal of paying off this
house being able to build wealth retire
early and have that financial peace and
i think once she's on board it's going
to make this whole thing a lot easier
so thank you so much for the call man
we're moving on to sue in cleveland sue
welcome to the show
hi i have a question about employment
for the summer for my youngest child
who
is not motivated to get a job and is
really resistant kind of pushing back
and i have asked them to fill out three
applications a week for jobs that are
nearby
and they still have not done that this
week and it's friday so i said you can
choose between today or tomorrow or i
will pick them for you but i'm just i
don't really want to go down that hard
road of i'll pick them for you i really
want to figure out how to help them
motivate
get motivated to figure out what they'd
like to do you have some thought
yeah well i do there's two types of
motivation
there's extrinsic motivation and
intrinsic motivation and extrinsic
motivation sue is what you and i do i
got three teens all right and it looks
like this uh hey
you can't go out with your buddies or
you're not going to this birthday party
until your room is clean and then that
room magically gets cleaned and so they
are motivated by either penalty or
reward
they're not intrinsic motivation is
where they're doing it because they want
to it's the person who gets up at 6am or
a.m to work out because you want to be
healthy because you enjoy what it does
for your day
so that's the difference and so
motivating a 16 year old to get a summer
job
you're not going to actually be able to
motivate them you're either going to
mandate it which is what you're staring
at right now and you don't want to do
that by the way let me just say this
that's okay uh in 2022 it's still okay
for parents to
mandate something you know like hey
you're gonna get a job you're gonna
shower or brush your teeth right so i
mean let's not be too worried about it
but let's go this route
um
what would be
an activity or something you think your
child would do um for money
but they'd be thrilled just to do it
whether the money was involved or not is
there some idea that's that kind of
jumps to the top of your mind when i
give that to you
um dogs in particular but animals in
general boom is this a boy or a girl
um a boy okay great so he loves animals
always has loved animals loves taking
care of animals yes
yep
what kind of jobs are you uh are you
suggesting that he applied for you you
mentioned two or three you had singled
out
yeah well we had looked at a dog wash um
company that's just up the street and
also a dog store that just sells dog
supplies
um we've talked about all different
kinds of things an art studio where yeah
but on the dog thing
yeah but you've identified that he likes
dogs so i'd sit with your son and i
wouldn't mandate this yet i'd say hey i
mentioned these couple of jobs the dog
wash the dog store
hey i'm okay that you don't want to do
it i just would want to know why is
there something with dogs that you'd
love to do because i'll help you i'll
help you come up with a dog walking
business or i'll help you with a pooper
scooper business which and ain't much
working with the dog but you know if he
doesn't like working with people and he
wants to make some easy cash i'd find
out what is
what he is resisting is it work in
general well now it's time to be mama
bear and tell him he doesn't have a
choice
but if it's
the certain type of work with dogs that
he's more interested in i'd steering
towards that this is a good
old-fashioned conversation see what
lights his eyes up and come up with
ideas help him there if nothing lights
him up
yeah i mean he's fantastic nothing the
relationship between work and money is
important if you can show him that and
he gets money for the work he does he
goes oh i'm in control now i can go buy
some things that i want to buy that
could be a great tool to get him excited
about the idea of work this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today
by ken coleman
all right ken so i'm in tune with our
social media what's going on over there
really people are saying i learn a lot
from you fingers on the pulse yeah
that's you that is me and so here's what
i'm seeing on the ramsey social media oh
people are looking for extra income and
they're turning to side hustles here's
some direct quotes from social i've been
searching to make some extra money on
the side i'm looking for the best
part-time online remote job
opportunities what's a good side hustle
i can do from home as a pregnant mom of
a toddler looking to pick up a side job
to make extra income people are feeling
the pinch of inflation they're trying to
find that margin and side hustles can be
a great way to do that when you're not
in a place to move up in your career to
get more income that's
right temporary raise yes that's a good
way to put it yeah yeah
so with that on social media i'm on tick
tock as you know you call it the talk i
call it the talk which infuriates uh
james but here we are anyways and my
three teams which is why i do it
just collateral damage that's adult
trolling is what that is ken yeah yeah
so uh we found some a lot of videos out
there on tick tock telling you how to
get rich quick and passive income which
that word alone
it hurts my brain passive income
right no work involved just money shows
up mailbox money i like to call it so
we're going to watch this video and then
we're going to share some legitimate
side hustle ideas to give you folks uh
some fodder so let's play that video
here are the five fastest ways to start
making passive income at any age for one
starting a vending machine business with
just two machines you could be making up
to a thousand dollars per month you're
going to find those vending machines on
websites like facebook or offroad number
two is you're going to start a lead
generation business every time somebody
fills out a form on your website you're
going to get paid anywhere between 15
and 1500 some people are making
thousands per day doing this number
three you're going to start a couch
flipping business find couches for cheap
or even for free on sites like
craigslist offer up or facebook
marketplace you can sell each couch that
you get from anywhere between 200 to 600
four if you're going to sell digital
planners on etsy you can make these
digital planners for free using sites
like canva this person has sold over 60
000 digital planners for 11 each that's
over 680 000 business number five is
going to be in the comments below like
and share
no i see what a tease i see what he did
there these these tick tockers they know
what to do
everybody wants to know what number five
is we've got more than that though now i
got to tell you when he first did couch
flipping i wasn't sure if this was some
new type of thing where you get paid to
come over and flip somebody's couch over
flip the cushions over yeah i didn't
know what that was no that is that was
one of the only legitimate ones that i
would go yeah i do that yeah i'm
actually kidding i think i think the
idea of we were talking during the break
the idea in today's world with you know
all the different websites where you can
go buy something at one cost put a
little bit of love into it you know what
i mean maybe fix it up maybe just clean
it i mean you think about couches right
now put a little steam clean on that
thing and flip it and make three four
500 bucks more maybe oh yeah you go to
yard sales goodwill and you start doing
the research don't just buy things
willy-nilly hoping you can flip it but
actually look it up on ebay look it up
on craigslist facebook marketplace see
what they're selling for and then go i
can get this for three dollars i can
flip it for 30. yeah this is worth my
time let me tell you the place that i
for
we've got a list here we're going to get
into a list i'm on this flipping idea
and this this is this is kind of a
personal dream of mine but i don't have
the talent
i would flip cars in today's environment
if i was mechanical like if i could fix
something up or let's say my brother was
was mechanical or uncle larry was
willing to go in it with me i'm not
kidding you i would be buying cars
and fixing them up flipping them up and
flip them and making really good money
right now you can really do that if
you're playing cash right you gotta have
some cash so some of these people are
going ken i don't have the cash to do
that but i'm telling you if you're
looking to you got some cash and you're
looking to really build a side hustle
for a lot of reasons that this idea of
flipping other products is that's big oh
i'd be all over it now a lot of people
want the remote work from home amazing
side hustles and the truth is the ones
that involve physical labor are the
things that people are willing to pay
more for yeah and so i like looking at
do you have some physical talents it
doesn't have to be talent are you
willing to go dog sit and mow lawns and
do all those kinds of things in your
neighborhood to make extra cash versus
some of these ones online you're making
pennies at a time you're making five ten
bucks it's not going to be a meaningful
amount for a lot of the side hustles so
i wrote an article uh for ramsey
solutions it's entitled 27 side hustle
ideas to earn extra cash we're not going
to hit all 27 but we're going to
highlight a couple some of our favorites
some of our favorites george what do you
got so uh number one for me is deliver
groceries oh really yeah so now i know
gas prices are high but if you've got a
car that has you know gets good fuel
economy and you're willing to drive
around and you like shopping and do it
with other people's money that's fun and
i use this service all the time for
myself and my wife when we don't want to
go to costco or target you know you get
shipped or instacart sign up for one of
those you start driving around yeah and
what's fun is they give you a free
membership if you're one of their
drivers
so there's a bonus all right i like uh
tutoring oh that's tutoring online in
person let me tell you why i like this
this is an in-home deal maybe uh in your
home or maybe in someone else's home but
we look at the education landscape today
and kids are struggling the pandemic put
a lot of kids behind
certainly if you're in an area where
you've got some upper income areas where
they're looking for some tutoring and
you're really good at a certain subject
online tutoring around the globe right
or certainly around the united states or
that in person tutoring i think that's a
great way to rack up some cash yeah if
you've got a skill set you've got the
knowledge other people need it yep use
it another one for me is dog walking or
pet sitting we just heard from the
gentleman who's got this amazing dog
concierge business doing boarding and
training there is big money here because
as you know ken uh us americans we love
our pets so much we spend so much money
on our pets were willing to do anything
for them at any cost not me
well there's a point of no return sure
i'm not saying that but you know you'd
pay for a dog boarding oh sure there's a
there's a place called a pet resort here
in town they charge like 100 bucks a
night yeah i could stay at a nice hotel
for that amount yeah no so no there's
good money in that though and it really
is we pay for some doggy daycare in the
neighborhood people to come let out the
dogs take the dogs on a walk it's easy
money a 16 year old could do it and
they'll pay you 10 15 20 30 bucks to do
these things yeah i tell you one i like
is just finding uh an area where people
are searching for help with tasks you
know it could be
could be organizing cleaning finding
areas where homeowners are people that
are busy and they've got some additional
income and they're going i just rather
someone else do this for me i would be
looking in that general area and you
know again this includes mowing lawns or
you know whatever i told a story years
ago on our show that of a young man who
bought a fishing boat cash
by creating a pooper scooper business
i mean you think about it he just walked
around his neighborhood and said i'll
come once a week
and uh scoop the poo
wow and who's not gonna like are you
serious and he charged reasonable rates
dog owner's like great i got my yard
cleaned once a week i don't have to deal
with it and this kid had more business
than he could possibly keep up with yeah
take advantage of that the culture of
convenience nobody wants to do anything
and we're willing to pay other people to
do it that's good and so mowing lawns is
a great one i've got a guy who comes by
with his kid and he's teaching them the
relationship of work and money and we
pay him 10 bucks every two weeks to come
mow our tiny little townhome backyard
because it's too much for you it's too
much i don't have a place to store the
lawnmower ken there's nowhere to store
it george campbell's postage stamp size
yard is too much for it it's too much
but here's the thing the neighborhood
facebook groups if you get into those
and you say hey
i'm free to mow lawns it's 20 bucks a
yard
you will get people in droves coming to
you because it's hard to find reliable
people who show up yeah and do a good
job if you do those two things you will
crush it in your side hustle yeah yeah
absolutely i love it so a lot of ideas
on there go check out all 27. you can go
to ramseysolutions.com
uh search for side hustles there and
that article will get pulled up great
work on that ken and one thing to
mention is time talent and target yeah
so here's what we need to do when we're
thinking about a side hustle and we're
thinking about making extra money we
want to start with those three t's so
time
how much time do you actually have
to be able to commit to a side hustle to
make money let's start there let's be
realistic so if we have five hours a
week ten hours a week we start with how
much time do i actually have can i give
to this work the second thing is talent
now this is not about dream job so
passion and mission don't matter when i
talk about those three elements it's
talent alone this is temporary money
temporary i've got a skill and otherwise
uh a tool
that i can use to make money and then
the third thing is what's my target
right am i trying to make ten extra
thousand dollars to get out of the baby
step two faster or to fill that
emergency fund in baby step three what's
my target and i'm locked in
on those three things and i know it's
for a season that'll help you with the
focus that you need to find it to get it
to do it to win with it love that great
framework and remember there's really no
such thing as passive income it takes a
heck of a lot of work to even get to
that point so focus on active income
actually doing something right now it's
amazing how that works yeah good step
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by ken coleman can
you know this about me one of my
favorite things to do one of my
spiritual gifts is giving away dave's
money i know you share you share in that
gifting yeah you and i have been
privileged to do it many many times at
live events and here we are doing it for
all of america well that's what we do
with the ramsey cash giveaway so we're
giving away five hundred dollars every
single week in may plus a grand prize of
three thousand dollars in our ramsey
cash giveaway so think about all the
things you could do with that extra cash
we were just talking about side hustle
ideas this is the best side hustle is
just to win giveaways that would be nice
so if you want to enter go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and the
cool part is you can enter every single
day so set a little reminder on your
phone make it your home page on your
computer for the month of may and enter
every day no purchase necessary but you
got to be 18 or older to win so sorry
kids if you're out there this isn't for
you
and we're not stopping there either to
help you crush your financial personal
and professional goals we are putting
our number one best-selling books and
tools in the ramsey ten dollar sale
that's up to 67 percent off so here's
here's my question to you ken what's the
last thing you bought for 10 bucks
wow that's a really good question uh
it's an interesting price point yeah it
was probably something to chick-fil-a oh
that makes sense probably what's your
order at chick-fil-a uh i like the
grilled nuggets
grilled nuggets wouldn't take you for a
grilled nugget guy really yeah what i
mean not the picture of health no i just
thought you were more of a handheld
sandwich kind of guy well i really love
their spicy chicken sandwich while we're
talking about it but i think my go-to
order is uh
is uh the the uh the the grilled chicken
nuggets i'm going to water side of
pickles yeah this is how we keep our
physique
listen man america's wondering what the
secret is no no they're not i don't know
they're not
i love it well here's the deal you can
spend your money on a lot of things and
times are tight right now and i'm glad
the inflation hasn't hit us at ramsey
it's not the 11 sale it's the 10 sale oh
that's keeping our promise so that's a
very you can spend 22 bucks and go to
the movies not including popcorn or soda
you can spend 10 bucks for almost two
and a half gallons of gas here in
nashville
or you could get a life-changing book
you can get our proven plan for getting
out of debt like the total money
makeover for 10 bucks you can get ken's
get hired digital course to help you
land your dream job for just ten dollars
yeah an entire course for 10 bucks
that's ridiculous how am i i used to
feed my kids selling it like that i
gotta talk to you it'll just take longer
that's all so check out the ramsey 10
sale and don't forget to enter the
ramsey cash giveaway every day at
ramseysolutions.com
all right dave joins us up next he's in
charlotte north carolina dave welcome to
the ramsay show
hey guys how are you doing today great
how can we help
yeah i appreciate you taking my call uh
i'm in a little bit of a pickle here i
uh i'm in baby step two right now and i
really was
cooking with some gas and unfortunately
this week i lost my job my primary
source of income sorry here man sorry
and i had yeah
thanks guys i uh
we had me and my fiance had plans to uh
pick up from charlotte and actually move
over to tennessee
uh my
lease is up in my apartment on uh june
17th and uh
i don't i'm not 100 sure what to do and
to be completely honest i'm not sure if
i want to try to get back into a career
that i was in doing because i wasn't
enjoying it at all okay that was my that
was my first question yeah so
um what were you doing
i worked for a mortgage company um
before that i was in banking for five
years so i kind of stayed under the same
house but
uh what kind of money i was doing uh
what kind of money do you need to make
what kind of money do you need to make
i was making
40 between 45 and 50 depending on
bonuses okay and so um what have you
allowed yourself to wonder about because
i know you have when something like this
happens to somebody they start wondering
what could be
what should be um
what are you thinking about if you were
to not go back into banking or the
mortgage industry what would you want to
try what would you want to do
no limitations no limitations yeah okay
yeah i i always kind of had an affinity
for computers and stuff and once upon a
time i was going to go into
doing computers and i decided not to and
but uh why did you decide not to
no i i wanted to explore the financial
path a little bit more and that's why i
kind of branched off in the mortgage and
from where i was i was originally from
western new york and sure i was doing
banking up there and all right so dave
dave let me tell you something
sure so so dave technology is the
hottest
career path
on the planet right now it's everywhere
it's in every industry so when you say
computers
do you mean technology type work
specifically do you mean working on
computers help desk stuff what are you
talking about
any or all of the above just a way to
you know build a career is basically
what i'm looking for i'm not just
looking for a job in a paycheck i need a
career there we go okay so two things
we've got to solve the urgency and that
is you need a paycheck pretty quickly
correct
yeah
yeah so you don't have enough margin so
right now your number one priority is
get a job
okay i don't even care what industry
it's in
because we need stability and here's the
good news dave you're in charlotte north
carolina
uh and the job market is hot hot hot
pretty much all across the country if
you got to work two jobs right now to
bring in the equivalent of forty to
fifty thousand dollars you can do that
would you agree with that okay
absolutely okay good so we have a short
term strategy which is two jobs one job
i got all this experience in banking and
mortgage can i hop over to another bank
or another mortgage company in the short
term to stop the bleeding meaning
no income coming in all right now
then i want you the next step is i want
you to really explore
what technology computer work you would
like to do do you want to go into cyber
security you want to become a developer
do you want to be like one of those
apple geniuses that george is always
talking to me about that can fix
anything you know you've got to
right but listen you you got to create a
list of i think i'd be interested in
these three things so then we go talk to
people who are actually doing it
you live in charlotte north carolina you
have plenty of relationships you could
sit with somebody who's in technology
and computers and find out what's your
day look like good bad and ugly
um what does it take to get qualified
how much is it going to cost me to get
qualified how long will it take these
are the questions you need to get the
answers to now i'm going to give you my
book from paycheck to purpose okay so
hang on the line we're going to give you
that book
and that book is going to help you walk
through this process okay
but it is not as difficult as it seems
once we get stable again so we want just
a j-o-b
where you've got the talent to pull it
off keeping the check coming in decide
whether we're moving to tennessee we're
going to stay in the charlotte area
that's the decision needs to be made
right now
because this might be that push out of
the nest that gets you there yeah and on
top of that i want to gift him if you're
okay with it ken the get clear career
assessment because this is something he
can take in 15 20 minutes i just took it
the other day and it was super helpful
for me yeah and good news is i'm in the
i'm in my sweet spot yeah you and i'm
going anywhere but this could be really
helpful for our friends dave and dave
what this will do is help confirm if
technology computers is a great
direction for you based on who you
uniquely are so hang on the line we'll
give you the assessment the get clear
assessment and the book from paycheck to
purpose awesome
this is a big question a lot of people
whether it's a job loss or they need
extra income they're going am i in the
right field they're having kind of this
existential crisis which i think is a
great thing long term it is and we're
also in an environment right now this is
mind-boggling we're now close to
38 million people have changed jobs
since august of 2021 folks they're
calling it the great resignation if
you've not heard that term in the media
these are the facts and so when you're
talking about that many people changing
jobs
people are paying attention they're
going oh larry move jobs and then becky
move jobs and so it all said well wait
everybody else is moving am i supposed
to move they want to be left behind or
left out and so
the other thing that's going on that's
really driving this is companies are
offering all kinds of great salaries
you could start at walmart and target
today for 20 an hour wow you ready for
this i saw a sign the other day uh one
of our listeners of the ken coleman show
sent this in and we shared it on the
show
i should have showed it to you james it
was a taco bell sign help wanted
and it was a sign in front of a taco
bell and they said uh
great pay all the things and they said
and cell phone breaks
as in like remember the smoke breaks
well now it's for the kids you can have
a cell phone break you can get all the
talk for 15 minutes here we go twice a
day catch up on your instagram this is
what companies are doing to try to get a
time to be alive
hey george can you handle the next
segment by yourself i'm gonna have james
give me a
cell phone break oh i thought you're
gonna go get a gordita crunch i thought
i inspired you to eat that's wonderful
hey that puts this hour of the ramsay
show in the books my thanks to my
stellar co-host ken coleman all the
folks in the booth keeping the show
running and you america we can't do this
show without you we appreciate you
listening and we'll be back with you
before you know
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell joined today by ken coleman and
we're here for you america here to help
you take the right next step with your
money your life your career your
relationships so give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you need
some confirmation affirmation motivation
education inspiration that's what ken is
here for wow i'm just the eye candy i'm
gonna tell you that was it's like you
prepared to say that i know you like
words i do that's uh that is you're a
smith of the word sig promise
oh i see what you did there thank you
uh-huh colleen joins us to kick off this
hour she's in springfield illinois
colleen welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely
i have a granddaughter who's nearly 17.
wow she's worked a part-time job since
last august
and i would like to start a roth ira for
maybe invest in some mutual funds but
i've been talking it over with her mom
and dad and her mom seems to think eye
bonds are better
and all i know is that they are tied to
inflation but i don't know very much
about them and i was just wondering what
your thoughts are on those well colleen
that's a great question and you're very
wise
very wise so here's the thing eye bonds
are going to lock your money up and
there's a lot of fine print when it
comes to these eye bonds a lot of people
have been asking us about them should
they be doing it and there's just better
options when it comes to investing it's
kind of this awkward it's not great for
short term and it's not amazing for long
term and so it's this weird in between
and so i'm not a huge fan of the eye
bonds but i do love the idea of opening
up a roth ira for your granddaughter now
this would be a custodial ira right
right
okay uh and she does have her name
probably
yes she does okay
i'm a fan of that side i mean have you
looked into other options for her what
is the savings for what's the goal here
uh just for her retirement okay
not college not a car just retirement no
get her started so that maybe when she
gets out of college she might contribute
to it and i'll probably put a little bit
in when i can and
by the time she's uh 75 years old why
she'll have a good-sized chunk oh
colleen you're the best grandmother ever
like ever
will you be my grandma yeah george and i
would like you to be our grandmother as
well how old are you colleen
uh 75 wow so you're you're thinking how
do i create a legacy for my children's
children that's a really cool right
that's really cool do you have money
what's your retirement look like
uh well i've got about a million and a
half wow yes
this is awesome and colleen this is the
fun part about this call so you're right
your daughter's wrong and you get to
tell her well i'm still right after all
these years i called this guy george and
he told me the eye
bonds yeah the roth is absolutely the
smart plate
um it's not just
i've always wanted to go with and
there's three other grandchildren
younger than the one that's 17 so
i'm just waiting for all of them to get
a job before i can start a roth ira if
you tell them hey as soon as you get a
job we're opening this custodial roth
ira and you show them some numbers of
what that money can turn into their eyes
are going to light up and go i'm going
to get a job tomorrow
absolutely that's awesome so the reason
i asked about what is this for is if
it's for retirement i'm good with that
but if they needed to access the money
earlier i was going to mention something
like the uniform gifts to miners act or
the uniform transfers to miners act the
uggmar the utma uh not fun to say really
won't need it for college they've got
529 accounts oh great these kids are set
up yeah yeah that's incredible they're
not too spoiled
no well hey that's what grandmas are for
colleen we're so proud of you way to go
yeah and i would definitely go with that
custodial roth ira awesome all right
we're moving on to john he's in
chattanooga tennessee john welcome to
the show
hi there thank you guys sure how can we
help so my question i'm pretty new to
ramsey and baby steps and all that um i
have the book the total money makeover
on order so i'm gonna get that and
freshen up on it but i'm curious about
getting my spouse on board
i've kind of started to talk to her when
i started talking gazelle intense and
this and that i kind of got a little
roll of the eyes and i'm just wondering
if there's some good bullet points to
toss their way
well uh did you lead with gazelle
intensity is that the first thing that
came out of your mouth associated with
it no no no okay definitely not okay
because that one will that'll freak some
people out right um
so george i
weigh in here so this would be my john
this is how i would do this is that
instead of talking about all the
sacrifices all the gazelle intensity all
the budgeting all the things that you
must do to win in the baby steps i would
first start with the end result the
destination you know we call it
financial peace
university for a reason because on the
other side of this
is financial peace and then not just the
emotion of that financial peace
john but also the freedom
to truly like live whatever dream you
have you know dave says you're new to
this but david said for many many
decades you know uh if you live like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else and so i would start
with
here's where we are now
babe do you like how it feels now around
money and what do you think she's going
to say
it's not ideal it's not ideal so we get
her there right and we go she
acknowledges you acknowledge we're on
the same page things aren't ideal they
certainly could be better and they
certainly we'd like for them to be great
and so she's she's going okay i got him
with you on that one and you show her
what the end result could look like
retirement accounts trips
whatever whatever whatever
you two dream together for a little bit
before you try to walk her through all
these uh baby steps where it's gonna be
really really hard so here's my point
when you get her bought in
to a desired future
well then there's no convincing her
anymore george oh yeah i love the idea
of having that vision ken and having
those shared goals before we have shared
language we have to have those shared
goals so sit down with her john maybe
you guys go on a little date night and
say here's my goals here's my heart
behind wanting to do this are you on
board will you go on this journey with
me and if she says yes to that and you
guys come up with those shared goals and
you start getting excited about that
future then you're going to be willing
to do what it takes to get to that
future that's right and so i'm going to
give to you uh financial peace
university because you said you got the
book but you don't have fpu right
no what is fdu so fpu is our proven plan
our video courses nine lessons our
flagship product to get people on the
path and i think going through that with
her yeah she's gotta be on board with
you watching these videos having
conversations i think that will get
people excited that's one of the best
tools we found to get people on board
and when you hear the debt-free screams
a common denominator is we went through
fpu and that was the catalyst started
everything so here's the great part john
dave does all the hard work right he's
going to be the bad guy you just sit
there and go i think he makes some sense
what are you guys
like dave and george and rachel be the
bad people here because they're going to
make it really really palatable
so hang on the line kelly we'll get you
that that's part of ramsay plus which
includes every dollar plus our premium
budgeting tool once you guys get on a
budget because it's tied to that shared
goal and that amazing vision man you
guys are gonna be unstoppable so good
luck with that i know it's a tough
conversation a lot of people struggle
with getting the spouse on board but
when you do you will create some amazing
amazing momentum this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and we are taking your calls the
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you need
some
push in the right direction a right next
step for your work your money your life
whatever it is we are here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five marks joins us up next he's in
tampa florida mark welcome to the show
hey how you guys doing great how are you
i'm doing fantastic
um just had a question for you i'm
trying to plan for
uh taxes next year so
as of today me and my wife just
completed baby step number three
awesome um
yes i'm feeling great there but this
year i got a new job and i'm 10.99
um and so
all that money we used that i got
we put towards the student loans to
finish them off this year
um so now that's done and now i saved up
you know three or six months worth of
expenses
i'm just trying to think um you know how
do i plan ahead for these taxes and also
you know we have a third child on the
way so we're looking to get into a
bigger house at some point in the next
you know two years or so
i'm just trying to think of how do i
save while also making sure i'm covering
my taxes yeah well the way i look at it
when you so you're not paying taxes
right now as a 1099 employee and so the
onus is on you
yeah and so i look at that as i don't
actually have all of this money it has a
name and it's uncle sam it's the irs and
so don't treat it like it's just money
coming into your budget treat it as if
okay we have 70 percent of this and the
other 30 percent we're going to sock
away in a savings account so that we can
do our estimated quarterly taxes
are you doing that currently
um
kind of mentally i'm really i'm just
throwing everything into a savings
account now i'm going to tell the air
the irs i mentally paid my taxes this
year
that's good enough i want to try that
one as well what do you mean mentally
you mean it's all your entire paycheck
is in one savings account
uh yeah so my wife's worked as well and
so that's pretty much covering our our
mortgage and our monthly utilities and
all that so really everything i get is
just going straight to savings wow
more so a house savings account yeah i
haven't really separated out just for
taxes what tax bracket are you in or do
you think you will be in based on this
new job and income
um
me and my wife combined uh we'd probably
be right around 300 000 for the year
right so you know what your percentage
is
uh with the whole 35
i think that's a safe that's the safe
play you're obviously saving 100 right
now but to george's point you need to
put a name on it not just all in the new
house fund so the uncle sam fund i'll go
with george's uh very witty uh uh advice
there the uncle sam fund is at least 35
i mean i'd probably make it 35
yeah i think that's a safe bet and
anything left over if you go oh all
right taxes were less that's great news
you've got some extra money to put
towards your next goal but what i would
do is start to calculate okay what's my
what's my taxable income going to be
this year what's the tax burden going to
be and then divide that into quarterly
payments and make sure that you're
logging into the irs website and making
those estimated payments every single
quarter that's what's going to help you
avoid any penalties and fees and fines
later down the road
okay
quarterly payments quarterly payments i
would also seek out one of our tax
advisors yes you know one of our
endorsed local providers at
ramseysolutions.com because a good tax
advisor
is going to give you not just
general advice we gave you but some very
specific things that you can do
to minimize your time to minimize your
tax burden uh you're keeping records
things you're able to write off i mean
there's a tremendous amount of benefits
to a 1099 income if you have the
discipline and you do i mean my goodness
you're already socking the entire check
away so discipline's not the issue for
you
it's strategy so i'd go see a good tax
advisor
somebody who you trust and everything
they explain makes total sense to you to
where you wouldn't even really need them
after that initial advising part and
that's how you make those quarterly
payments and you won't end up paying too
much and you can obviously look for tax
benefits and tax savings
good stuff all right thanks for the call
mark appreciate it we're moving on to
brittany she's in denver brittany
welcome to the show
thank you so much for this opportunity
this has been a debate from uh my
husband and i for oh
seven months
glad to step in the middle of it is he
on the phone too or is he not around
no he's with the baby in another room to
go away
that's good how can we help
so um
we do not know if we should keep our
home that we're leaving them living in
right now
and we have an opportunity to buy a
house in oregon another state away
for a flip
so we don't know if we should keep it
and rent out this house or if we should
sell it
and
[Music]
yeah if we should sell it or
um rent it out because we eventually
want to move back here and be in this
house
or be in this area and have it as a
rental when we move back so are you
planning on moving to oregon
yes for a couple years so you're going
to buy this house move to oregon and
then eventually you want to come back to
denver
correct
well
do you have the money to pay for this
new house in cash
we do not
okay so we're talking double mortgages
here because your current house is not
paid for
no it is not we owe 230. um
and
uh we do have
an opportunity for we have somebody in
line to rent it
we actually have a studio that we rent
above our garage and then the house
would be separate and we would get three
thousand dollars
total
for the rent
and my mortgage is 1740.
what's the new house cost in oregon
so it costs 440. we are selling our
business here when we move and we will
get a hundred thousand dollars for that
how do we able to drop
what would the house sell for that
you're currently in
about 5.50
okay so that would leave you i'm
guessing after closing probably around
300 you'd net from the house sale if you
sold it correct yeah and then 100 from
the business you could almost pay for
this oregon house in cash do you have
any money in savings
we have 32 000.
okay but that's your emergency fund and
everything
no no my emergency fund is 16 000.
fantastic wow well here's the night on
baby step five so go ahead i we are we
are not fans of becoming a real estate
gurus before your current home is paid
off we're not fans of having multiple
mortgages because it increases your risk
decreases your financial peace so if i
woke up in your shoes i'm selling this
house
i'm going to take that 300 plus 100 from
the business plus my savings and i'm
probably going to scratch up the other
eight and pay for this oregon house in
cash which means you don't have a
payment in the world
right so you're going from having two
mortgages to now no mortgage and then
how fast could we save up to buy another
house in cash and then we can get into
real estate investing once we have our
current home paid off and let me just
add to george's brilliance here on this
he's saying what he's saying is right
because you're looking at making uh if i
heard you correctly about 1300 bucks a
month if you were to rent your current
house right with them and that's if
nothing ever goes wrong that's right
that doesn't include expenses to keep
the house up because you've got a house
i mean a room over the garage plus a
full house that you were the landlord on
so and you're a long distance landlord
and you're long distance thank you and
so if you look at the numbers i don't
know which side of the debate you're on
but if you look at the numbers for
renting it doesn't even come close to
the money you're going to stack away by
doing what george told you by not having
a mortgage
down the road
yeah like immediately like as soon as
you move to oregon you start stacking up
money because you don't have a house
payment the real question is whose side
are you on
is your husband in favor of selling the
house or does he want to keep it
no it's we both are were
we figured you would say sell it but we
were hoping we could get away with
renting it
listen you can get away and get away
with it who wants to live a life of
getting away with something you have
permission to do what you want brittany
and you know what the truth is you're
not going to die from either decision
but i'm here to help you create
a build wealth as fast as possible the
right way and to me that's to reduce the
risk and you know if this if with this
mentality you go well we should go get
another place with very little down and
rent that out and you start to get
starry-eyed at all of the upside while
removing all the downside removing all
the risk and what if the tenant doesn't
pay and what if the hvac goes out we got
two mortgages we're stressed out of our
eyeballs and we're trying to do it all
long distance
that's stressful i'm already i'm
stressed out thinking about it britney
so that's our plan you can do with it
what you will the advice is free and
some say it's worth what you pay for it
ken
there you go this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell joined by the
effervescent ken coleman host of the ken
coleman show can you came hot off the
ken coleman show right before this show
well it's just you know you got a job to
do and what i do is i walk out from that
studio to 150 feet over to this studio
wow that must have been why why i was
ever vested what a sacrifice i'm just
trying to shock you with big words ken
well you didn't shock me that's a word i
like to use
but it was well it was well played i'm
not sure it's true but i liked it i'll
keep trying thank you well ken we are
headed out on the road next week oh i
can't wait we had a great time in vegas
an amazing crowd boy what an electric
crowd that's the only word we can use to
describe it yeah pure electricity and we
hope to recreate it in orlando
so we're going to be in orlando next
week we've got a few more stops planned
for the fall but this is it for our
spring tour of building wealth live and
as you all know there's so much crazy
stuff going on right now people are
looking for direction on how to handle
their finances day to day but they're
also struggling to see how it's even
possible to build wealth in today's
economy in today's environment
so we're going to walk you through all
the crazy and teach you the steps to
build real lasting wealth financial
principles that we teach are the only
principles that work in prosperous times
and in hard times and no matter where
you are with your money today you can
get on the path to building wealth
that's what this event's all about so
we're headed to orlando may 19th and
this fall we're headed to phoenix
september 13th sacramento on november
1st minneapolis november 10th san
antonio november 15th and it's rachel
cruz myself dr john deloney ken coleman
dave ramsey the whole gang is going to
be there it's going to be a great time
so go get your tickets today because
they are selling fast people are excited
to just get out of the house and go to
an affordable event tickets start at
just 25 bucks bring your friends it's
going to be amazing go to
ramseysolutions.com
events and reserve your seats now
all right ken so on your show you talk
about work and career and purpose and
with that comes uh all the trending news
of remote work
and now the shift from remote work to
hey guys we're coming back to the office
oh boy and it's created a big stir
hasn't it oh man i mean you have people
that are up in arms about this you know
there's data out there that says that uh
nearly 60 of people said that they'll
quit their job
if they have to return to the office wow
people that are remote workers i mean
they have really jumped into the whole
sweat suits and rocky road ice cream you
know it's amazing because just a few
years ago remote work was a rare concept
there wasn't a ton of full-time career
remote jobs out there yeah you know more
and more people were doing it but we're
talking about a small percentage of the
american workforce then the pandemic
hits and of course everybody goes home
for a while right and uh so you get some
people that go man this is my jam and by
the way fine
until you you potentially hurt your
professional possibilities in your
income yes so i want to show everyone an
example of the kind of stuff we're
talking about the stances people are
taking and of course we're going back to
tick tock uh ken's favorite social media
platform i love to be on the talk and so
this one's about why are remote workers
being forced back in the office check
out this video
i still find it very hard to believe
that a lot of corporations are forcing
their employees to come into the office
after working from home for two years
it's very obvious that you do not need
to sit and look at them all day long now
i'm not naive i know that many of these
corporations have these big buildings
and major real estate investments they
just simply just can't go under so
they need to get the employees back in
the building and they need them to use
the building otherwise they'll have to
renegotiate these leases get out of
these contracts that they're in and they
probably just don't want to do that and
it may not be
um financially beneficial for them to do
so so i get that
but it's just always a situation of
choosing
business over employee well-being
because if employees want to stay home
and they did a great job working
remotely when they were forced to and
now they want to stay at home full-time
why are you forcing these hybrid models
or them to just come back into office
there it is all right so
this is a common sentiment this is not
this is not an aberration that's not
something out of left field this is this
lady is expressing what millions of
americans believe
um i take issue with the fact that
corporations are asking people to come
back in a hybrid model i'll break that
down in a second but corporations aren't
asking people to come back because they
need to use the building
you know that's that is not the issue
okay
they if if they don't want to use the
building and they wanted to to go all
remote they could get out of those
leases they could sell those buildings
yeah and they got some examples of this
right down the road here from ramsey is
a healthcare company yeah that has been
empty empty completely empty so it's not
about usage it's not like a country club
and we got a bunch of workout machines
that are going to get rusty if people
aren't on that is not what corporations
are doing what they want is they want
more teamwork
collaboration and a better culture
i mean i'm reading these headlines every
day
and and you see the ceos that are saying
we want a return to work to a hybrid
model and it's for reasons of we believe
we need that connectivity and we as
human beings are relational now here's
the thing for all these folks that like
this this lady uh who are so against it
um there are there are millions of
people are going i'm lonely i'm
disconnected it's created depression a
lack of productivity because you're just
always in the same environment there's
no there's no boundaries between your
home life and your work life
so there's a lot of negatives to this
work from home
uh this idea of flexibility and then i
want to just comment on hybrid so hybrid
is i mean
it's it's letting people work from home
a couple days a week or three days a
week in the office two or three days a
week and this is becoming widely adopted
to the point that i think a couple of
years from now i think it will probably
be the
most common form of work environment
that we see as a hybrid model i just
think that's where we're headed but my
goodness
you're willing to not go back to work
you're willing to change jobs to quit to
start over to maybe put yourself in a
position where you gotta scramble all
because you don't want to leave the
house
i think you have to be cautious with
that
you know but you do what you do you
uh but i would not make this a line in
the sand yeah not when they're offering
you the hybrid model and to be clear we
are not against people working remotely
now at ramsey we all work in the
building and that's something you know
when you sign up for this place this is
how we operate right but the idea of we
were in person then we weren't remote
and now we refuse to go back and they're
forcing us
i just don't believe in this narrative
well this is the wrong that's a very
good point george the word forcing are
they forcing you
there's no armed guard showing up at
your house telling you you have to go in
they're saying if you want to work here
we need you in the office you have free
will
this is america
you can say pound sand i'm out
you know if that's what you want to do
do that don't gripe and and act like the
evil corporate man wants me back in the
office because he needs to see his cubes
filled this is nonsensical snowflakery i
just made that that's a great word i
like that yeah so what it comes down to
ken is you're not entitled to anything
because you're an employee
you are entitled to your opinion
and you are entitled to your choices oh
that's what you're entitled to here's
the takeaway outside of that you're not
if you want to work remote go find a job
that allows you to work remote fantastic
is that it that's the summary we solved
it
yeah wow
they should put us in charge of
something but here's the deal this is
good there listen this has always been a
money show it's always going to be money
focused
what i'm cautioning is is that you were
to take a step backwards professionally
and financially all because
you feel you have the right to work in
your conditions all the time and the
company has no opinion about it it's
it's nonsense
so don't hurt yourself over this get
over it yeah i i got to tell you i don't
see what the big deal is
going back to the office uh the hybrid
model i i i can see if you love remote
work and you can get full-time remote
work go for it i'm all for it be remote
be i i can't be away from people that
long i got deep problems you love me too
much i love george i need to be around
george you know what i'm saying said no
one ever but what's the problem with a
little bit of work in the office for
some collaboration some culture it's
like we're ignoring the fact that we're
humans and that we're relational yeah
well one thing's for sure work has got a
lot more complicated and you've got to
start figuring out where are my values
what do i want for myself and for my
family where do we want to live and the
beautiful thing is you get to decide
you have free will you have agency over
your life you control your destiny and
the moment you think it's in the hands
of the employer the evil greedy crooks i
gotta just back up and say hey hey you
have choices remember that take control
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell next to me my friend
ken coleman and this is the ramsay show
we're taking your calls this hour triple
eight eight two five five
is the number david joins us up next in
columbia south carolina david welcome to
the show
hey thanks a lot guys absolutely what's
going on with you
um i hear you all talk a lot these uh
people who are like in her twenties and
and they think they got it tough and i'm
thinking you guys got decades ago i'm 51
so i just want a little bit of hope here
i guess because i feel like you know 51
is the new like 91 or something 51's the
new 30 man you got to twist it
so um you know we're not anywhere not
even remotely where my wife and i where
we want to be and everything but you
know again i'm 51 she's i'll just say a
little younger than me i won't get her
age um i'm not stupid um but you know we
really don't have anything built up yet
now we're not in
dire straits we're not one of these
people that have you know fifty thousand
dollars in debt or anything but you know
we wanna be somewhere we have twins that
are eight years old now
so you know we've got a ways to go
before they're off on their own and
everything and so kind of the main thing
i want to pour some hope here and and
some direction i guess
okay well what's your financial picture
look like do you have any debt
i would say my estimate is around 8 000
between credit cards and some medical
bills okay
and then i have a car notice i do have a
car note and a car loan okay and that
out all adds up to 8 000.
well no the car is another about 10.
what's up okay
don't don't lie to me come on i'm trying
to help you
okay so how much money do you guys have
to your name in liquid savings cash all
that
uh let's say about
thirty two hundred thirty two hundred
dollars to your name and have you
started investing for retirement where
are you guys at on that front
i did um i started a 401k a few years
ago and also some 529 plans for our
daughters
and then a friend of mine made a good
point he's like stop investing right now
until you have your everything paid off
and then go back to invest and i said
you know i don't want to do that because
i got some good momentum doing it
but and i didn't want to lose that
because it was i was proud of myself
but he said don't keep you know putting
that money in retirement right now get
off the debt and then you can this is a
wise friend
i i'm with your friend on this i know
you're feeling the pinch david because
you're 51 you're going well i want to
retire with dignity
and so i got to be investing but then
you're trying to clean up a mess over
here and so you've got a lot going on
right now and so i want to simplify it
for you uh by helping you focus on the
baby steps this is the path to financial
peace and your friend is right we got to
clean up this debt and use those
payments you were making to now help you
build wealth
you see where he's coming from there i
do and he actually teaches um financial
peace at his church so awesome i know
he's a wise person
good so as far as the hope side it's not
too late for you you can still retire
with dignity you may not have 20 million
dollars in the bank but you absolutely
can do this so you can get out of debt
get the emergency fund in place
start investing pay off the house the
kids are gonna be okay for college
they'll figure it out they got 10 years
before we we nail that and so just take
it one step at a time one day at a time
but focus your efforts on one thing at a
time and right now that is getting out
of debt and so a thousand dollars is
your starter emergency fund beyond that
the rest of the money is going towards
this 18 000 of debt
yeah and and another thing i should
probably mention is we live in a very
small house that i actually lived in by
myself and you know i'm married and have
now two children
and this this is not i want we
absolutely have to move to a bigger home
that of course is now going to cost a
lot more um and we will clear a little
bit on this house not very much but we
have to move to a bigger home just
because
you know we got four of us now instead
of one
so that's something we have to do now
you sold the house how much would you
net
about twenty thousand you'd net twenty
thousand could you
rent for a while if you did that in the
columbia area
i would probably pay more in rent than i
would in a house next how many how many
rooms how many square feet that we have
now yeah
um 1100 square feet two bedroom one bath
and it's just the twins just the
eight-year-olds
right just the twins and my wife and i
uh two boys two girls boy and a girl two
girls two girls so why is there not i
don't think you have to leave i i gotta
tell you i'm gonna push you on this
okay
tell me why you have to leave the two
girls can share a room you got two rooms
and they do they and they don't have a
complaint about it they don't ever you
know voice complaints about being with
sister but
i just feel like we need the space we
need
that and also to be in a nicer part of
town than where we are and just
so are you wait
wait i'm not saying that that those are
good desires
i'm not saying that those aren't good
goals i'm questioning whether or not
they fall in the category of have to
right
right are they in the want to no
question
and i'm not listen i'm not i'm trying to
challenge you because if you can hang on
for another year in that house
george how does that change the picture
well if any if one year from now picture
this you're out of debt and you have a
fully funded emergency fund you can
breathe you don't need physical
breathing room right now you need
financial breathing oh
tweet that
very nice george so uh david what's your
household income
write it right at 98 i'll call it 100.
oh my goodness yes between the two of
you tight george i'm sitting in this
house okay what we need to do is get
control of this fantastic income you
have because clearly it's not working
for you right now where's all this money
going are you guys on a tight budget
no that's one thing we really need to
sit down and we're not good i'll be
honest we're pretty poor about
we don't communicate when she writes a
check and i write a check or
you know i spend money on something we
don't really communicate a lot now and i
do have a side hustle that makes about
about four thousand dollars a year so
it's very variable but on average about
four thousand dollars that i do okay
well step one is you guys getting on the
same page and getting on a budget and
i'm gonna help kick start that for you
as a gift i'm gonna gift you financial
peace university our nine lesson video
course and every dollar plus our premium
budgeting tool it's all part of ramsay
plus so hang on the line kelly's gonna
pick up and we'll make sure you get that
code and get signed up for that what i
want you to do though sit down with your
wife and create what might be your very
first actual budget with every dollar
right list out all of your income list
out all of your expenses and actually
track what you're spending and go hey
you know what we're spending 900 on food
we could trim that down you know we can
cut the subscription for a temporary
time hey what if we sold this start to
get on a game plan get excited get
creative and you're gonna start to feel
that momentum especially when you watch
all the videos with her in financial
peace university that's gonna light a
fire under you guys when you have that
shared goal and you go we're getting rid
of this debt yeah and we have a number
on it it's going to be 19 months for us
to be completely out of this and then we
have our vision for this new house but
right now you're floating through life
just wishing and hoping
yeah yeah
so i appreciate the help because i i
just feel like i had to hope being you
know i hear these kids are under 24 and
like you got you got decades to go
and
you know when i'm 51 i feel like i don't
have that much fun no you're fine you're
fine
walk out the baby steps yeah listen stay
in that house please
your your eight-year-old twins don't
even care they don't even know this is
you and your wife getting over your your
your long-term desire knowing that it's
not as far out as you think it is if you
do what george told you yeah i'm not
worrying about investing in 529s right
now let's let's worry about that another
day right now let's get out of debt
let's get on a budget let's get the
emergency fund in place so that we can
breathe and there's a 100 chance you
will have to retire there's a 50 50
chance the kids go to college
and so let's worry about that later
maybe they can get scholarships they can
work part-time but what happens is
people in your shoes they end up being a
burden to their kids because they retire
broke and now the kids have to take care
of them i can't tell you how many calls
we get like that and i don't want that
for your future or your kid's future
okay so have a long-term mindset david
think about what the 10-year picture
looks like man in 10 years we're gonna
be completely out of debt with a paid
for home
and investing for retirement we're going
to be able to retire with dignity
because we have very little expenses
yeah that's what i want yeah yeah you
know this have to
versus want to this is a risk word i'm
telling you gotta really lock in on that
and go wait a second do i want this or
do i
have to do that you know it's like is
there a emergency that's pushing a
reaction or is it just oh i really want
this and you know i'm just going to tell
you you know what i tell you why i love
to give that particular piece of advice
to somebody in that situation
years ago i went back to the house that
me and my brother lived in with my mom
and dad when i was in high school i
couldn't believe how small it was it
looked like you could put a matchbox car
in it comfortably like like it was that
small but i was like i never i had this
little teeny tiny room i didn't know
kids don't care i'm in the same boat one
one tiny bathroom for the four of us my
room barely fit the bed and i'm a little
guy
[Music]
but hey this is the kind of sacrifice
you've got to make if you want to win
long term we got to have a long term
mindset no more half dues no more had
twos
let's get to work
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant wanna see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell your host joined today by ken
coleman and we are here for you this
hour america give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's eight eight
eight eight two five five two two five
k michelle kicks us off in the
philadelphia area okay michelle welcome
to the show
hi and thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it absolutely i
okay i hope everyone's doing well i'm
just returning to work uh it'll be three
years in september i'll be 60 in january
and i work for the city as a librarian
uh i was a caregiver for over 10 years
so i don't have any
uh i just call it savings or anything
like that
and i'm trying to make a decision about
where to live building apartment right
now but i'm kind of scared to take a
look at any type of work it's 15 years
means i'll be 75.
i do have to not say that about 60
in credit cards i have a pseudonym is
about 120 000 so
i had spoken to someone about a co-op
and in theory it sounded
not sure what i should do as far as how
when you're concerned
okay speak directly into your phone for
us as we continue here but i think i got
most of it how much total debt do you
have
well with the student loan which is 120
000
it would be 126. so how do you have 120
000 in student loans at 60.
okay well i started um grad school
in uh new york and the week i got there
i got into announcement and they were
student loans they weren't excused
and despite the fact it was partially
their fault the astronauts and so
when i became a caregiver i went back to
school online and i left off the loans
because i wasn't living off my parents
um you know the savings for my mother
so that's where the large student loan
comes from
oh
i'm so sorry well i mean this is a mess
to clean up especially at your age what
are you going to be making with this job
with the city
well um i talk about it my grade which
will be 60 000
next year however i am working on
another
edition side job but it requires some
training which is in project management
okay
well here's the thing as long as you're
able to work you've got some hope here
but the you could live to 90.
statistically speaking if you've made it
to 60 you could live another 20 years
and so uh what you can do is get rid of
this debt and retire with dignity i
don't know that a house is going to be
in your near future to be honest with
you
um so i want you to get your income up
did you graduate from the program that
you were in
i graduated with a master's in library
science from undergraduate and
journalism and i haven't gotten my
project
management certification but i'm working
on that
okay
i want you to make sure that we're
utilizing whatever you programs you're
certified in to make sure we get your
income as high as possible which is what
uh you know ken coleman would want you
to do is get that income up as high as
we can yeah i'm just curious um
how much more do you anticipate that
you'll be able to make on the side with
this project management certification
um i plan on probably doing a change as
i go up the ladder with my job
so that my income will increase it's
just a matter of the time that i'll do
this
um you know with
working for the city you have certain
steps just like you do with the federal
government yeah but i foresee you know
it's bringing up from
60 probably
to maybe
80 or so okay yeah and i would really
encourage you to look outside of city
government state government certainly
with that project management
certification because project management
is one of the hottest
let's call it a trade for our
conversation right now
an opportunity for you to really grow
and
you can do this across industry so it's
a very flexible uh very very uh um
i think upward moving opportunities for
you and right now um you've got to make
as much money as possible
and and so you called and started asking
about a house you no the answer is
you're not oh no you can't be thinking
about a house
no yeah i knew i couldn't afford a house
but i was projecting in the future it
would be a founding a house or co-op or
just staying in an apartment or even a
condo so
whatever is affordable and safe i mean
whatever you can you know i want you to
try to keep this thing around 25 of your
take-home pay going towards rent that
may be hard to do in this in this market
but whatever you can find that's
affordable in a safe area that's what
i'm going with for now as we try to get
your income up but this is a this is a
tough situation you've got six figures
in debt at almost 60 years old and so i
love that you're thinking about the
future but we need to have been thinking
about this uh long term in the past as
we try to tackle these student loans
tackle the debt so here's the thing stop
the bleeding we're not going to touch
debt anymore we got to get on a plan get
your income up so we can start attacking
this debt from smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate that is
baby step two using the debt snowball
method so put a thousand dollars aside
the rest of the money you have goes
towards the debt once we're done with
that let's build up this emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses so
that you can breathe and so you can
retire at some point i don't know when
that will be for you as long as you're
able to work i think you got to keep
working
yeah and i mean selling anything and
everything i mean it's like
you're
you have to get some margin and and i'm
going to tell you something in this
situation if she can add that project
management certification with not much
more time or money that is a good move
to to give her some professional options
and and look okay
government work
a lot of people love government work
there's good jobs good people doing
things that government work but you
don't have the upward mobility
that you can have in the private sector
yeah and so i really would encourage her
to look outside of city government state
government work um for the purposes of
she's got to maximize her income and i
mean quick yeah well part of the the
issue i have with the public student
loan forgiveness program is you got to
stay in those public service jobs for a
decade yeah well which means your income
would not be as high as if you were in
the private sector and so to hang on to
that all for them to hopefully forgive
your student loans is a bad idea but you
brought it up george so i feel like
here's a minute i opened up a can of
worms there's not gonna be student loan
forgiveness you heard it here first
folks it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen i mean look you gotta
understand how much money the federal
government makes off of those
interests uh those loans and the
interest on those loans it's a big
business
and and this is a political year
and they're going to dangle it out there
as a possibility
and the reality is is like if you look
at the numbers
of the amount of people in the united
states that don't have college degrees
it's now like 64 of americans wow okay
then
you look at wait a second the taxpayers
are gonna pay for your student loan
forgiveness you went and got the
education you signed up for the debt and
now we're just going to wipe it away
it's actually not the winning political
issue that they think it is
so for a myriad of reasons i'm trying to
dash people's hopes not to be unkind
but to put
this into perspective
the government is not going to come
riding in on the glorious white horse
and uncle joe's not going to wipe your
student
student
loan dead away it's not going to happen
i think they need to put their hope in
someone who can actually help themselves
the person in the mirror well said
that's what we should focus on
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ramsey
personality ken coleman and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five sarah joins us up
next she is in san antonio texas sarah
welcome to the show
hi george hi ken thanks for taking my
call
absolutely
i'm hoping you can help me with this um
i'm not really happy with my job i want
a career change and what i'm interested
in will make me substantially less money
um because of
my salary and the lessons i learned from
dave ramsey you guys i feel like i'm in
a good place financially right now so i
don't know if i'm about to go off on the
wrong track
give me a snapshot give me a snapshot of
your financial picture
um
so i have um a house paid off worth
about 350 000. whoa that's awesome way
to go
and i have about um
500 000 in retirement wow how old are
you
i'm i'm 42. wow excellent way to go
you should say how young is she george
well you know yeah i'm sorry kenneth i'm
not good absolutely so uh and sarah so i
guess you've got i mean
you're you've gone through all the baby
steps right you're you're i i'm on baby
step eight yeah there we go i like the
sound of that well this gives you
options i'm hopeful yeah you have
options how big of a pay cut would this
be from what to what
it's right now i make um
about a hundred and ten thousand
and i'm but i wanna i wanna be i i want
uh i wanna be a teacher good for you
what do you do now
oh i'm an accountant okay great
okay so
what about going down so uh where let's
see you are would you plan to stay in
san antonio
um you know i i don't know uh right
right now i guess i could go anywhere i
mean i like san antonio i
right now it's just mainly the pay cut
that i've i've only been kind of worried
about right well what i'm at the reason
i asked you if you're gonna stay in san
antonio is because if you've not done
your homework on what the what the
teacher pay in your area is that would
be a good piece of information to get
have you done that oh yes yeah i would
be going down to like between like like
50 to like 50 to
mid 60s okay have you run an exercise on
what that would look like how that would
affect your lifestyle with that new
salary
um well right now i don't even spend
that much i mostly eat at home and um i
i go out with friends but we don't go
out to like
yeah you know fancy restaurants yeah so
the point is is that you can handle it
it's not even going to hardly affect you
at all as it relates to what you feel
and your normal your normal rhythm of
life correct
um i guess my only concern is like right
now if i if i leave my current job that
there's like pretty much no going back
well wait a second why would we want to
go back to something that you don't
enjoy
well mainly for financial stability like
i guess it's don't you have that
sweetheart you are you are very stable
yeah yeah i guess it's just after all
the years of working it's you know
ingrained in me to kind of keep making
money in the idea well you are but you
are getting a lot of anxiety i get it
sarah and and it's because you're so
wise with money you are dealing with the
emotion of sticker shock from 110 to
let's call it 55 000 split the
difference between 50 to 60 and you look
at that and everything in your brain is
telling you that that is silly and crazy
to do which is why you called us am i
right
yeah because i mean it just goes against
like everything
everything that i i've learned from you
guys well well no it doesn't no it
doesn't what
because you have walked through the baby
steps you do have financial peace and do
you know that that ramsey solutions a
few years ago did the largest study of
net worth millionaires that has ever
been done
any guess as to what the third largest
group of net worth millionaires was in
the united states and is
and them teachers
oh wow and number two was accountants so
either way you're going to be a
millionaire yeah let's not worry about
financial stability yeah you're 42.
you're going to keep investing your
salary it's going to be less yeah even
if you didn't invest another dollar that
500 000 over the next 20 years you're
going to be a multi-millionaire so
here's the no pun here intended but the
million dollar question is why do you
want to be a teacher what's the why
um
i guess i've always enjoyed teaching um
it's one
i'm i'm sick of a desk job right now
i've been like my spine is starting to
hunch over i feel like different
position
um who do you most who do you most want
to teach
oh um i i guess like uh kids between
like like i would say the junior high
school level
now see that's very interesting that's
very specific and i'm glad so that's
middle school
yes you see see as a teacher someone who
wants to teach and instruct you could be
a corporate trainer and make six figures
so i'm challenging you a little bit on
this to say does it mean you have to be
a public school teacher but if that's
what you want to do the great news is
sarah you have walked out the baby steps
you're in baby step seven you can work
like no one else because you're on your
path you've done all the hard work so
this is it's counterintuitive to say all
right i'm gonna go for making 110 to 55.
i get that but the reality is for you it
doesn't matter it won't even hardly
affect you at all so who you want to
teach
and why you want to teach has to be your
focus
yeah i guess
i just wanted to make sure i'm i'm not
i'm not in a grass is always greener
situation okay i'll give you a test for
that have you hung out with any teachers
and talk to them people that are
teaching on the junior high or middle
school level and talk to them about the
ends the outs the good the bad the ugly
yes and
um yeah i i feel like it i would enjoy
it it's it's just that financial aspect
you know i didn't i grew i grew up in a
in a poor family so
i guess
sarah you've done so well and i know
it's hard to make the shift where you go
from intense to intentional but you've
done so so well
and guess what if you're a teacher
making 55 guess what you can do on
nights and weekends if you're really
strapped financially you can do some
freelance accounting
you can do some tutoring there's always
going to be ways to increase your income
but right now you're saying i hate my
life i hate my job and yet i'm doing so
well financially so that's not worth it
you're worth more than that and you're
42 years old you could have another 20
years plus in your working career to
have an impact to have that joy that
you're craving
yeah yeah i mean i
that that's kind of why i was calling
because i know that the show has said
that money's supposed to help you live a
life of purpose and right now i don't
feel like i'm living that but i mean um
so you're not i just wanted to make sure
sarah you are on the right path you have
been on the right path you're exactly
where
when we talk about this idea of
financial peace and then working on
purpose you're there you were created to
fill a unique role sarah
in your work that means you are needed
and it also means you must do it and
your soul is slowly slipping out of your
body
every day you go back to that job is
that true or false
oh yeah i i do not like it well then
life is too short to live that way life
is too short to work that way you're
fine sarah write down all of your
financial fears and then write down
worst possible scenarios and then figure
out what the solution would be for that
worst case you lose your job worst case
the stock market goes down for a few
years
what do you do you're going to be okay
you have a paid for house you don't owe
anyone any money
and you can always you are in great
fields of work that we're always going
to need yeah that's right and so take a
deep breath congratulate yourself go out
to celebrate with your friends and go
hey i didn't know this but uh i'm pretty
much a millionaire i want to celebrate
let's go out yeah and then let's talk
about what this next step looks like for
you to get this education to become a
teacher and step into that role
okay all right well i appreciate the
help the advice thank you guys sarah
you're amazing hold your head high
you're amazing i want you sarah to think
about
the kids that you're gonna have the
opportunity to come in contact with
who you will shape
who you will influence in a way that
maybe no one else could
that's your why um and ken you and i
have both had amazing teachers in our
lives who have impacted us and we can
sit here all day and tell stories that's
right but we need teachers who really
want to teach who want to instruct and
impact this next generation and i'm
grateful for people like sarah who have
done the financial work to have options
to get to switch career paths at 42.
that's inspiring listen to that song
learning to fly there it is
more of what you love coming up this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsay
show i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why they are the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more and you all know i
love a good deal so use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from colin in new
hampshire i'm 23 engaged and the only
debt i have is student loans in a car
payment i currently work in a job with a
big company that i don't like i don't
plan on making a career there but i earn
60 000 and will soon get a 15 raise
on top of a four thousand dollar bonus
this year the work life balance isn't
great and the job is exhausting i've
been offered a new job with a smaller
company doing something that excites me
they have a great company culture and
the position is more aligned with my
career goals the problem is their pay
range is only 55 to 60 000
with small annual raises do you think
taking that job uh that pays less but is
more fulfilling and aligns with my
career goals is the right choice
uh okay so um i wouldn't take the job
they're already very close to what you
make uh with the 60 now that doesn't
include your 15 raise that you're
getting and you think you're getting you
hope you get but you never know and the
bonuses um so i wouldn't take it unless
they matched your current 60. you know
you can just say hey thanks for the
offer um
but you know i'm not going to switch
jobs for less and so you know if they're
in the 55 to 60 range i would think they
would at least meet you at 60.
um
and so from that standpoint yeah i would
take it i mean you're not going to last
long at this other big company you've
already set it here
uh you know you don't like it work life
balance isn't great although i got to
tell you for a 23 year old who's been
working for maybe a year i i
question it's already worn out i
question why you're exhausted and what
does work life balance look like for a
23 year old i'm sorry
i'm sorry i don't have a whole lot of
empathy on that one yeah but that's
neither here nor there the answer is
i'd leave for 60
i wouldn't leave for less than 60 but
you're not going to stay at this big
company long so the fact that you can go
to this other company and assuming get
the same amount 60 000 and then get the
occasional bumps but that doesn't
include you getting promoted
so the reasoning in this entire question
is is a little bit all over the place
you don't stay for a bigger paycheck
when you've
verbalized the fact that you can't stand
it and you're exhausted
because eventually that bump in pay
wears off and we just are about two
checks we just recently took a call
where uh this this woman's making great
money and hates it and now is willing to
take
half the money in order to step into
what she loves so uh colin you told me
you've got debt and here's this this is
a trigger word for me ken when people
say the only debt i have
is student loans in a car payment which
we don't even know what that equals to
that could be 50 grand 60 grand let's
own up to the fact that we've got a mess
to clean up so on top of maybe taking
that new job i might be getting a side
hustle or two until i can clean up this
debt uh so that i'm not in pain for a
longer period of time making payments
with my income because guess what the
pay cut doesn't matter that much when
you don't have payments
it's amazing how that works but i gotta
warn you you might be exhausted that is
part of it buckle up colin this is
adulting this is how it works well
appreciate the question and uh congrats
on the impending wedding and uh good
luck with your career move
joining us next osiris is in colorado
springs osiris welcome to the show
thank you thank you for uh taking my
call i truly appreciate it we're honored
to take it how can i help
um so this question i've
had for
forever now um i'm 34 and
i have two teenager kids
and um
obviously you can only do so much so
either the kids or a career
i have the kids and i'm still thinking
pursuing a career
uh in the medical field
but
um
i'm debt-free except for my mortgage and
i don't want to go into debt i don't
want to risk it
so one of my passions
is being joining the military
and why is that so that's kind of
um
i'm very money conscious i don't want to
say frugal but i'm more conscious about
cost expenses and being or using the
money in the most productive way
similar with
a career or a why
you said you were passionate about
joining the military i'm curious what is
behind that passion
for me
when i say i love a job or i love a
career or i love anything in relation to
what brings in the income
it has to be
productive to me in several ways the
military comes because i find it the
most productive there's a lot of
productive work you could do out there
though
what kind of work would you do in the
military let's just fast forward this
and assume that the military said come
on osiris you get any job you want in
the military what kind of work would you
want to do for the military in the
military
that is really hard question for me
so the way i am and i know it's probably
hard to believe the way i am is that i
tend to love any job that just
practically stays like i'm i'm grateful
to have a job
you said you love any job that pays but
but this is most jobs then
all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna give
you four i'm gonna give you
osiris let me give you four categories
to choose from okay let me try to make
this multiple choice when you think
about work that you would really love
now i want you to suspend this current
thinking which oh i just i have a great
attitude i love any job that gives me a
paycheck no you don't you're very
grateful for it but there's a difference
between gratitude and love like love is
a strong bold word like passion is like
the the root word of passion uh in the
latin is is pati which means to suffer
means i'm willing to suffer
uh sacrifice and eat on rice and beans
right to get out of debt that's that's
what we see passion on the debt-free
stage when people do their debt-free
scream so being grateful for a check
is not passionate so let me let me ask
you this i think there's four basic
categories of work okay there's people
work
there's ideas work that's kind of the
space george and i are in we think about
ideas and conte that's kind of work we
do
there is process type work where it's
very administrative organizational
process driven project manager that kind
of stuff and then the last category
would be things so think mechanical
building
fixing designing something of a physical
nature so when you think of people work
idea work
process work or things work
what sticks out to you what made your
heart go who
when i gave you that anything
um it would be public speaking
okay
all right so that's that's people i'd
put that in the people or ideas work
it's probably a combo okay so what do
you love about communicating
um
teaching teaching people there we go um
i like learning when i teach okay so
here's one here's the thing if you're
gonna go the military route you would
want to see what are instructional type
jobs within the military but you see the
theme here
because we're not going to limit you
just to public school teaching
um we're not going to limit you to
uh corporate training we're not going to
limit you but anything that is in of an
instructional nature
that's something that you know you enjoy
and so now you can be grateful but also
love the work and that needs to be the
decision that we make not just join the
military and then figure out what they
give me you know if you're gonna join
the military uh
what what's an instructional position
that i could eventually work my way into
yeah and uh take into account osiris you
know where where are the teens at how
soon are they going to be out of the
house i don't know that you could you
know get deployed and be able to find
challenges here for the teams and what
happens to them yeah and so there
there's something to think about and i
don't know that it's military because
everything you told me it started with
medical we jumped to military that was
public speaking so here's what i want
you to do we're going to send you ken's
get clear career assessment to help you
get a little closer and that multiple
choice quiz you'll take will really
narrow it down and give you a purpose
statement that shows you how your
passion your talent your mission all
interact so hang on the line kelly's
gonna pick up we're gonna get you a code
to take that get clear assessment i hope
it gets you a step closer and gives you
a little more homework to do as you
navigate what this new career path looks
like yeah a couple fun questions when
you get your results who do i want to
teach
where do i want to teach
how do i want to teach it's going to
open up a lot of creativity and ideas
that you can begin to then test and
formulate thanks so much for the call
osiris this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
ecclesiastes 7 8. the end of something
is better than its beginning
patience is better than arrogance
edmund hillary said it is not the
mountain we conquer but ourselves
good stuff there this is the ramsay show
jake joins us up next in chicago
illinois jake welcome to the show
hey george hey ken how are you we are
great how can we help today
all right well i'm at like kind of a
crossroads financially and
work-wise and
relationship-wise this week i started a
new job about five weeks ago
in a totally different career path i'm
about halfway through my 10-week
training with this
company
and uh
i just i'm not getting the direction or
leadership i need for my team manager
and then also in about two weeks i'm
going to be selling i'm going to be
closing the deal on my house i'm going
to be selling it
uh the house has paid off and i'm going
to be moving it back in with my parents
and i just don't know what to do with my
money or if i should be holding on to it
and trying to look for the next deal
in the real estate market or just trying
to invest it i just
i don't know what to do
okay i'll let ken hit the career part
first then we can get into the
financials yeah what makes you think
that uh that you're not getting what you
need
in this training process
well there's there's two parts to the
training one once done through the
corporate office remote
and then once done with my actual like
team manager in my region and the remote
the remote parts going great i'm getting
all the necessary tools that i need
uh from my training advisors but as far
as my team manager uh i've been doing
my due diligence to reach out to that
person and uh like last week i was sent
out or yesterday i was sent out wild
goose chase and kind of set up for
failure
and she admitted to it too later in a
phone call with me that like hey i just
kind of set you up for failure to see
how you would
uh react to it it's like i'm five weeks
on the job i have no idea like this is
totally new to me totally different
industry than what i'm coming from i'm
like i was not expecting this
well how did you handle it
i uh i did have to make a decision um
was it the right one
and my like right now it resolved the
issue but it's just delaying it for
another five weeks
okay so i mean are you just as you're i
mean so this was a technique of hers it
may say it may be a horrible leadership
technique but it was a technique she
owned it she did it on purpose see how
you'd handle failure or indecisiveness
or whatever so do you believe that or or
do you
not believe that because you could
believe that and go i still think that's
just horrible bossary
or you could go i don't believe her
it could be her technique because i have
reached out to some of my team members
they're like yeah this is kind of how
she operates all right and it was just
new to me i guess but you feel whipped
yeah especially only being on the job
five weeks yeah but but i mean what did
you do you're not gonna get demoted i
guess what i'm saying is i want to
understand
what has just
whipped you you feel whipped emotionally
like oh my gosh like it was a technique
she does it to other people was there
any learnings from it do you feel like
there's no going back i mean what what
has caused you to be so deflated
i guess just the communication aspect it
was it's just really hard to communicate
with this team manager whereas where i'm
used to
uh you know
i'm used to face-to-face interactions
too this is totally new to me to remote
learning and remote work yeah but you
said the remote learning is doing well
it's the face-to-face learning that
you're having issues with
yeah
all right so my point is is i wa george
can handle the money stuff pretty
quickly on this but i mean what's what's
what's the
which way you lean in here are you done
are you willing to give this thing a
chance and give yourself an opportunity
to to learn and grow here
i would like to give myself an
opportunity to learn and grow here i
just i don't
it's just i don't know
did you talk with the leader about this
in detail about hey i understand this
was a goose chase to see how i reacted
to this is this going to be normal i'm
feeling like i need a little bit more
attention on training on this this have
you expressed that
i have not yet now you need to express
that you need to give yourself a chance
okay you chose this career path on
purpose or did you fall into it
no i chose this career path on purpose
why did you choose it
um well i came i came from a blue collar
background i went i'm 26 by the way but
i came from a blue collar background
right out of college i got my degree in
finance
and the industry i went into now is
insurance claims and i felt that it was
a good
aspect for my skills because i i've
worked with contractors in the past but
i also love working on small projects i
like dealing with details and numbers
and i thought that this would be a great
career avenue well can it still be
i believe so yes good so my point is
you're not you don't you're not an
indentured servant here you don't have
to stay at this company forever let's
let's stick this thing out and get some
good skills get some good experience
stick this thing out yeah i'm going to
use my grow my hard skills and soft
skills while i'm here and hey six months
a year down the road if you still don't
trust and respect the leadership move on
then move on but you're 26 you're gonna
be okay and on the house side you said
you had a paid for house that you sold
yeah i'm gonna in about two weeks i'm
gonna have a little like right around
295 thousand dollars and why'd you sell
it for this new career i have to it's a
proximity job so i have to live in a
certain region of chicagoland so
where my house is located i'm actually
in the city of chicago so now i've got
to move out to the top and your parents
happen to be in that area correct okay
so what's the long-term plan
the long-term well
this is gonna this might sound stupid i
was planning on
i was i'm in a serious relationship i
was planning on possibly buying a house
with that said person
in where my parents area is at suburb
but uh
i was looking like that's not going to
work out either so now i'm thinking the
relationship's not going to work out
correct
what makes you think that or know that
just uh dishonesty on a couple different
levels and just
one more reason to not buy a house with
someone you're not married to for sure
so let's take a pause here i'm going to
park that money in a savings account a
high-yield savings account we're not
going to get fancy and put it into the
market and invest it right now because
we just don't know what your future
looks like you may turn around and get a
home six months from now a year from now
and so that's not enough time to be
investing this money so just park it in
savings let it sit there it's okay
okay
thanks so much for the call jake
appreciate it justin joins us up next
he's in dallas texas justin welcome to
the show
hey guys um i'm i'm basically calling
because uh
i've hit a crossroads like the last
gentleman when it comes to like
kind of my career and uh
making a good living and trying to
follow the baby steps and everything
i've been
kind of davish on and off and
uh
a year and a half ago
i've paid off like 20k in the last year
and a half um good how much is left
um
it's kind of just like a personal debt
to my parents at this point i mean i owe
my mom like 9 000 for a car that i'm
currently driving
and
i owe them more money that they
they haven't
spoken with me and said like all right
this is how much you owe us or okay yeah
justin we're coming up against against
our break here so get right to your
question
um basically um
i i spoke to my mom about doing like a
data boot camp to try and get into the
data industry and get a job and she
thinks it's not a good idea because
a lot of those jobs require uh
bachelor's degrees and i don't have a
degree of any crime so i was
no that's not true
have you have you done your own research
so you can show mom with a lot of
respect hey mom the kind of tech jobs i
want to do data jobs they don't require
a bachelor's have you done that
i haven't seen that actually because
when i when i you know when i go on like
indeed i do see like these positions
like the qualifications for the
positions are like a bachelor's degree
or whatever but i know that for data
jobs like data analytics for instance is
what i'm thinking of i know that if you
have certain skills that like maybe like
even at ramsey solutions if you're
looking for someone to come through data
and figure out like what products you're
doing well and stuff like if i know how
to do that then you guys will hire me a
lot of companies will so you you i
appreciate you're going to job sites but
you actually need to do a little bit
more research so that mom can get some
buy-in and then you get some confidence
it's your decision not mom's
first of all but secondly i understand
her influence and she's trying to
protect you but it depends on the tech
job but you need to do your research
trust me my friend uh
betheltech.net go check them out
and on the other side we got to make
sure we cash flow whatever education
comes next i know you got a pile of debt
that might mean pausing on this but you
got to do it all with cash so we don't
have regret and payments in our life
thanks for the call that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books i'm
george campbell that's ken coleman thank
you to everyone in the booth making the
show happen and to you america until
next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you